[موسيقى]
تحديات عديده تواجه صناعه السينما في
سلطنه عمان فبالرغم من وجود مهرجانات
محليه عديده الا ان حضور الفيلم العماني
بحسب النقاد لا يزال خجلا في المشهد
السينمائي الخليجي والعربي اخر هذه
المهرجانات مهرجان السينما المراه والطفل
الدولي في العاصمه مسقط الذي اتى بمشاركه
81 فيلا اختار منها 41 فيلما من 14 دوله
اول مهرجان
يقام في سلطنه ككونك مختص في هذا النوع من
الافلام حيث دمجنا ما بين سينما المراه
وسينما الطفل واصبح لنا اول مهرجان وهذا
المهرجان يعتبر اول مهرجان
يدمج المراه والطفل في العالم ليلى
الحمدون بدورها تعارض بشده ارى بعض النقاد
السينمائيين القائلين بغياب السينما
العماني هذا اتهام انا ارفضه
واعتبر بان هناك
المسك من لوكيشن مثل ما يسموه
الاخرين لا يبحثون ولا يدرون احنا عندنا
مهرجانات قائمه حول همم يعني مهرجان
الكبير في مسقط وعندنا في الفتره الاخيره
انتقلنا الى مهرجانات في المناطق من جهته
يؤكد رئيس الجمعيه العمانيه للسينما
والمسرح حميد العامري ان صناعه الافلام في
السلطنه لا تزالوا بحاجه الى مزيد من
الدعم الحكومي والاجتماعي
معدي بنجاح عمليه سينمائيه اكبر تهتم بهذا
الشام طبعا هذه الهيبه لها ادوار كثيره من
ضمنها هي الورشه السيناريو وتاهيل
للمخرجين حتى دورات خارجيه
استقدام
يعني يعني حضور بعض الكتاب من الدول
الخارجيه والمخرجين
للتاهيل مبادراتهم تخرجوا بين فتره واخرى
في السلطنه لتشجيع هذا القطاع الصناع في
المك في عمان مبادره دشنتها الجمعيه
العمانيه للسينما والمسرح خلال مشاركتها
في اكسبو 20 20 في دبي انا ذاك بهدف في
تشجيع صناعه وانتاج الافلام السينمائيه في
البلاد مبادرات يعول عليها البعض والبعض
الاخر ينتظر المزيد عبد الرحمن العصيمي من
مسقط العربيه